tout le monde debout je t'avais dit 2
c'est tout ce que j'ai on va se faire un
ancien gepam cocaïne
ouais je sais voilà bien c'est comme
quoi vous aussi ah ouais exact je vais
faire
qu'est ce que tu veux faire tu veux que
je cambriole ce dealer pour tout tu veux
cambrioler un dealer à tout ce que je
veux c'est d'étudier de plus près si ça
ne donne rien ou d'attentats
quoique ces mecs entrepose là dedans ça
reste ici y'a rien qui sort jamais ils
font les livraisons par l'arrière mais
où ça va une fois à l'intérieur ça
excite la curiosité 1
je n'ai rien reçu de votre service à
propos de ça vous avez raccroché mon
téléphone
oui d'une manière si ce n'est pas du
tout aux chargeurs ça pourrait indiquer
que vous exercez une activité
potentiellement illégales de 200 dollars
ok très bien mais deux fois un
coffre-fort à l'arrière d'un magasin et
on l'a découvert précisément comment va
sortir à l'eau hier à l'eau aymen des
ressauts bord cool ou est-ce que tu as
planqueel vannes
pourvu que ce soit pas lui ça vaut la
peine de creuser à condition pouvoir
mener la faire jusqu'au bout et
discrètement la façon que tu as eu de
dire cette phrase là c'était trop beau
la porte du coffre est trop récente
si on attaque on va se heurter au
mécanisme alors à moins d'engager un
braqueur professionnel à justine antully
non au milieu ouvre là tandis sur halo
et donc ton ils essaient de percer le
plancher de l'appartement
exact d'accord nous voilà de mèche
on peut pas faire ça je sais que mon est
tombé au juste est à l'épicentre du rêve
américain
ou voilà ouvre là